hi class of 22
welcome to the gsb fam i'm kerry and i'm
recording this from the very hot houston
texas
hey class of 22 welcome to the gsb my
name is emily
so excited that you're here hello class
of 2022 i'm rob siegel a lecturer at the
graduate school of business and also a
member of the mba class from 1994.
we are so excited to have you here with
us you're about to go through a truly
transformational experience
the likes of which none of us have
actually really gone through the way
you're going to go through it
but we can't wait to see you in person
we're so excited to have you here and we
want to welcome you to stanford
while we can't be together as we
normally would be
in the classrooms or in town square we
are still an incredibly strong community
we know that this is a fall quarter
unlike any other
i'm not sure what the new normal will be
but one thing
that i can sure is that in that new
normal i might be able to talk with you
without this math it is gonna be tough
and we all have to stay
flexible which is lesson number one in
business one thing i wish i knew at the
start of my gsb experience
was to just breathe relax and
savor the moments that you will
undoubtedly share with your classmates
whether you are on campus or online this
quarter
we are here to support you be grateful
stanford is a magical place and it's
very easy to forget
to be grateful when you're overwhelmed
by everything
while the gsb offers a great community
and a great communal experience be sure
to have
honest and difficult conversations with
yourself
about where you are and where you're
hidden
i'll leave you with the five values of
the gsb
engage intellectually strive for
something great
respect others act with integrity
and own your actions welcome to the gsb